we need a president who cares about the
people
and loves the people he is somebody of
such extraordinary race and kindness he
will bring the exact kind of empathy
that is so badly lacking in this white
house I hope the American people when we
get to the White House
um know that we feel their pain we've
got to heal this country
well Joe Biden was supposed to restore
compassion and bring empathy to the
White House well here's that compassion
for the American people they look for
this right well this weekend he was
asked about the devastating fires in
Hawaii
will you come talk about the Hawaii
response Mr President
I gotta get to dinner back to the beach
imagine for a second that a Republican
president any Republican at all said
that
you think the media would let him get
away with it not a chance they were all
upset when Trump threw the remember he's
throwing the paper towels
they got all upset about that now as
Biden son himself on the beach GOP
candidates were in Iowa meeting with
voters at the State Fair now the crowds
were big I've been to the Iowa State
Fair before it's a lot of fun and they
were really big crowds for former
president Trump
but is this giving us a sense of what
the 2024 campaign season would actually
look like joining us now Victor Davis
Hansen senior fellow at the Hoover
institution Monica Crowley former
assistant treasury secretary in the
Trump Administration
um Victor I should say that right now
the Fulton County Georgia grand jury is
about to hand down looks like another
Trump indictment it's a total travesty
so Biden is going to hide while Trump is
in in court apparently the whole
campaign because this is looks like it's
the way it's going to you know play out
yeah I think Biden has settled into a
tripart strategy Laura on the one hand
he's going to be a virtual president go
to the beach then he's going to go to
Tahoe I guess next week not come in he's
on the beach while a whole a whole
beached city has been wiped out and he
can't even make one remark about it so
he's just going to retire and be a
construct and let the Obama Bernie
Sanders Elizabeth Warren ring
Wing continue to run the country and
then he's going to Stonewall all of
these looming indictments and then
they're going to
fixate on Donald Trump and they think
this is going to get us through the next
17 months it may but there's some
problems with it some of these
indictments are so ridiculous in fact
the majority of them that they're
building a huge pushback and Biden is
declining that we've been saying this
for the last two years but it's getting
very egregious now it's so obvious that
I don't know if it's going to be
sustainable for the next 17 months and
then finally unlike the uh Trump
impeachments or the Clinton impeachments
or the potential Nixon impeachment Joe
Biden is facing charges that are in the
Constitutional bribery and if he did a
quid pro quo for a foreign government
when the family received money and they
can prove that that's almost treasonous
so I'm not sure that he's going to be
just protected because there's a
Republican Senate so this is going to be
a very interesting 17 month he's in a
race against the truth to tell you the
truth
Monica Biden announced today that he's
going to send a one-time payment of 700
to every household suffering who that
suffering now now it's an interesting
number especially when you see it
compared to this headline U.S inflation
means families are spending 709 dollars
more per month
than two years ago
Monica so really needs to give people
fourteen hundred dollars I guess Maui
family is getting 700 each yes I mean
the American people are really suffering
a very uh drastic cost of living crisis
and it's uh directly out of Joe Biden's
hand in the hand of the Democrats who
once they entered office in 2017 excuse
me in 2021 they began spending like
drunken Sailors and created this drastic
inflationary environment Laura so here
he is he's going to give out checks once
again you know this is mailbox money
from the government money that we do not
have and cannot afford at the same time
sending an additional 25 billion dollars
to Ukraine while the people of the
United States are suffering whether it's
the devastated community in Hawaii
whether it's the people of East
Palestine Ohio whether it's the folks in
the Border towns whether it's the people
in collapsing cities Across America
people suffering from the fentanyl
crisis people suffering from higher gas
prices and skyrocketing inflation care
he does not care you don't care he sold
himself in the last campaign Laura as
Scranton Joe as somebody who's going to
Champion the little guy and instead he's
only Champions the big guy himself and
enriched and empowered himself
throughout his political career and
could not be bothered with taking care
of the American people
yeah I I think that's a great point I
mean he's cared about Wall Street the
big donors Victor who want him to
pretend to be tough on China so they can
get cover themselves but in reality of
course they're not they're not tough on
China
um but a reporter today asked uh the
press secretary about Biden's strange
decision not to even speak about the
Hawaii wildfires watch this Victor
the person I've given any advice that he
should not speak about Hawaii at this
point he had an opportunity he could
have stopped by to see us when he
arrived back clearly it is something
that is deeply concerning to him when it
comes to the father wildfires that we
have seen in Maui but certainly this is
he's the president right you're going to
hear from him
this is so strange are they are they
drafting a speech for him Victor they
can't just say this is a horrifying
event and we're here for you
wow I mean this is a media that this is
a media that criticized George
W bush because he didn't have big enough
waiters when he waited out in Katrina
and Joe Biden is the president United
States you should get off the beach he
should fly out to Maui he should have
c-17s coming in every hour with a big
airlift and treat these people much like
they are American citizens and you know
we treat people in different countries a
lot better than we do Americans and this
is just shocking that he's going to go
from as I said from one vacation to
another and from one beach side to a
Lakeside why people in Maui have no no
beach they're destroyed their lives are
destroyed and he doesn't seem to care
and he's a virtual president as I said
and at some point it's not going to be
sustainable each day the media is
struggling and frantically trying to
construct and recalibrate a presidency
that no longer exists doesn't exist
anymore
well really quickly Monica zielinski
snaps his fingers and sometime soon
after that he'll get something right and
the people of Maui are suffering and the
president's shirtless on the beach his
Beach it is a wild thing to care so much
about Ukraine and not really seem to
care much about the American people
across the board well Joe Biden and his
family have enriched themselves via
Ukraine and that corrupt regime and
corrupt players in Ukraine to the tune
of tens of millions of dollars so of
course he's prioritizing Ukraine over
the American people but this is what you
get with America last president Trump
put America First Joe Biden has America
and America's interests and the American
people last
yeah and that's the most compassionate
thing you can do care about the American
middle class especially and Donald Trump
did that Victor Monica thank you hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else